foreign
[Music]
Tucson and Colorado and Las Vegas I'm
coming there crystalia.com for tickets
Charlotte North Carolina Knoxville
Tennessee Little Rock Arkansas for some
reason Nashville and you know a bunch of
Canadian dates and Florida you know all
over the place Philadelphia go to
chrisley.com
get them tickets
uh and that's that for now so like And
subscribe before we get into the podcast
and here we go another episode of
congratulations
[Music]
oh [__] dude it feels like I haven't
done this podcast in
three weeks I don't know what's going on
maybe it's because I've done so much
since then you know just being a dad
just getting absolutely added to the
gills you know just absolutely I mean
dude he's he's different ah he's
different bleep it out because it's the
beginning but ow Christ's sakes he did
it again didn't he he got All Inked Up I
got all drawn Anna ah crap dude oh crap
dude
um but yeah uh so that's what's going on
my addiction's got to go somewhere and
now it's just getting drawn on so that's
cool uh you know I could be a heroin
addict but I'm not
instead getting all drawn on
um anyway I'm 43
you know people say it's a midlife
crisis but really I just think I'm the
absolute ship
hahaha
I'd rather marry a smart sensitive
caring woman than someone who thinks
they're the absolute [__] that's from a
few episodes ago no I don't think I'm
the absolute [__] as a matter of fact I
have insecurity problems and sometimes I
think I'm not worth anything but anyway
another episode of congratulations is
coming so
um yeah
uh we're having a good time in life my
son is good my other son is good my wife
is good uh my my dad and my mom my
everything's good man and it's too hot
in here but it's fine dude guess what
Los Angeles you know I just been
thinking I've been spending some time
thinking about Los Angeles and about how
it's different now it's been different
ever since covet and all that now it's
like really expensive it's even still
it's been expensive but at least at
least like we had it going right and now
it's like we don't really have it going
because it went crazy right
La went pretty woke and it's pretty
crazy but also though it's not really
that Sunny anymore but those days are
over because apparently the sun is
coming out on the horizon and it's going
to be sunny so that's going to uplift my
mood thank God because dude when I wake
up and it's cloudy out cloudy out
giveaway is absolutely sad but um it is
weird how much that dictates my uh
attitude yes dude
if there's a cloud in the sky I can deal
with it if there's like five guys in
this guy oh no he gets sad dude
basically he just gets sad because of
clouds I need to see that sun I need to
wake up and go out I'm like a flower
dude I need to go out sit in the Sun and
just take it in right just take it in
especially since I'm really into my
health lately just taking it in guess
what I ate yesterday salmon and rice
only dude that's it I'll be sick of it
for real soon thought about today when I
woke up baby I have more salmon and rice
I go yeah maybe once and then I want to
eat
other stuff because but I'm on a health
kick my babies Jesus Christ he's on a
health kick I mean what's going on
but yeah man uh I hit the gym a lot I do
only legs go figure
I do only legs is it an exercise if your
knees don't bend I don't know dude don't
talk to me about that I met my knees all
the time
so uh yeah dude uh got the yat got some
gaps done then they go remember don't
work out I say sure got home took a
shower then slept woke up worked out I
make my own rules right
I make my own rules
um I went to uh the gym and I did I said
maybe if I got get it on the arm it's
okay I could do my legs went did some
squats didn't ego lift I do not ego lift
I want to because of my ego but my other
ego goes like this hey first ego you
don't need to be doing that and then I
go like this yeah and we all agree and
my ego because my ego goes like this all
right fine
so I do a lot of reps I do a lot of sets
instead of just doing one right now
I still did squats the next day I did
deadlifts can you do that yes should you
do that I don't know there's a bit of a
mixed reaction on it should you do
big you know it's lags and legs yes but
it's more hamstrings the second one and
whatever I don't want to bore you with
all the details right
but uh I'm gonna be super tattooed and
super ripped so watch out summer
my wife is one lucky woman
yeah she actually says she wants me to
be fat so I don't know what that is but
uh definitely wives like to be make your
uh husband fat because then it uh it
keeps the threat situation at like a low
level right you see me yachted up you
see your husband got it up you see your
husband yeah it up and absolutely just
shredded the striations coming coming
out saying hi how you doing the
striations running for mayor right
giving speeches you want that no because
then what trouble because who looks at
striations and the added up beings
chicks and then uh oh right but you
gotta have a husband with a strong mind
that's the added to the gills and
striations are saying hi good morning
and he's still kind of you know what I
mean about that home family life so
yeah I do extra sets and I don't ego
lift ego lifting is when you're a guy
that wants to try and do the most he can
and It suffers the form Makes You Suffer
right right like you're doing deadlifts
but you're concaving over like you're
trying to suck your own piece
you know trying to do deadlifts and
you're not keeping the lats engaged you
just hunched over like a question mark
you know what I'm saying but I don't do
that man
um but yeah my lower back sort of [__]
but it's all good
um
but I just want my [__] to you know I
don't know man I'm talking too much
about it but honestly that's why you
come to this podcast for the
hard-hitting truths speaking of which
the grow or die merch is out I keep
forgetting to plug this on the podcast
but the grow or die merch is out it is
absolutely ill I made the grower die
come across the back of the shoulders so
you could see it if you're a big dude
that [__] spreads out real nice doesn't
look too small goes a little bit over
the shoulders spreads out real nice if
you're a [__] you know what I mean if
you're a guy who's got who's who who and
they filming movies on your back
because of the mountain ranges right
um and the open land in the space
so yeah go get that to grow dimerge
chrysalia.com and uh and that's really
been my whole thing it's it's nice being
you know a data too I spent a lot of
time with my my sons and my family it's
been fun man it's been really fun my new
son William uh spits up so much it's
he's like a sprinkler it's unbelievable
dude he'll just be also he spits up not
even when he's eating
like I get it to spit up after you're
eating you know you're eating the milk
right either whether it's formula or tip
milk you're eating it
and then
you and then and then and then just he
goes also it's so weird when a baby
spits up because it's not you can't say
throw up it's definitely spit up because
it's just
it's just they'll do it like in the
middle of stuff which babies don't
really do anything but if they were to
do stuff it's like they would do it in
the middle of stuff like they'd just be
like lint rolling just like this
just let let [__] just milk just let
it just
right all over the desk while you're
typing
but yeah William will just be chilling
in there but then we'll just be watching
TV or something and he just goes and I'm
like you haven't even eaten in [__]
two hours dude
how much is [__] not like hey stomach
decide when this [__] doesn't agree with
you earlier
you know his stomach's like my wife
always giving people like you know I
maybe they're you know what
maybe they had a bad day
and then me I'm like nah
I don't want to be around at all period
um
so yeah uh
I don't know I posted the thing it dude
the internet I only use Instagram I use
tick tock too I don't really look at I
don't look at Tick Tock I look at
Instagram it's the only one I look at
I think period I really think
um and
I posted a thing
on my podcast I think it was last
episode or two episodes ago where I was
talking about since it was pride month
look
I didn't even know pride has to do with
all of the the lgbtqs all of them not
just gay it used to be just gay and now
it's like yeah get them all involved all
right fine
dude
it's crazy how much
they're they're promoting this [__]
these companies okay now I don't really
give a [__] because who cares but but
dude I turned on one of the apps
like uh
I don't remember which one it was you
know I got HBO I got I got I got all
right Max I got Paramount I got Netflix
I got all the different ones I turned on
one of them Disney I don't know which
one it is dude and
I get it first of all I kind of think
everyone is kind of on the spectrum of
gayness right like you either don't I
think there's a spectrum right you
either blast dudes you think about
blasting dudes
or you just simply don't blast dudes
right now I think a lot of those people
who blast dudes are living their best
lives a lot of those people who think
who think about blasting dudes kind of
think that they should be blasting dudes
but they're not doing it because society
says and I think that a lot of the
people who don't blast dudes are over
correcting because they want to blast
dudes but then there is that Minority
we're really we just don't want to blast
dudes and that's where I fit in okay I
think unless my subconscious is really
really good
or bad I should say maybe it's
overcompensating right
but
I'll tell you right now to your straight
to your face I'm blasted zero dudes just
period zero kissed one guy and it was a
joke and it was in high school we were
both in high school and then we were
doing it we was like ah come on let's
kiss on the lips hahaha and I did it and
it was in front of some chicks and we
were all having a you know as a laugh
but it felt weird you know and I think
it actually felt weird because it felt
weird and I've never done it before not
because
it actually I was like stirring up some
[__] in my
because otherwise I'd be blasting dude
Central at this point you know me right
but um
anyway uh
if you turn on apps
first of all every three months is pride
month I don't give a [__] what everyone
says I I see it all every time there's
probably a month I'm like didn't this
[__] just no okay
sometimes I wish I was gay so I could be
like [__] this month man just let me be
gay and chill but this this is crazy
dude I turn on this streamer and it had
it was like celebrate your
you know
the gayness of everyone and then also
trans and then
and it had the people on the thing they
looked like it was they were shooting a
sketch
you know it was like
you couldn't tell if it was a guy or a
girl in a hat
and he was and then another person it
was like I don't know what that person
is and then they had two guys that
looked like gay guys and I was like cool
fine but then it's like I just want to
watch the floor is lava you know
and it's fine
but it would here's why it bothers me
because the corporations actually don't
give a [__] that's why it bothers me
because they don't care and so gays are
like I'm coming up look at this month we
have look HBO Max is involved really
they're just involved because of the
money aspect
but then
I don't know man I don't I don't know I
don't know I don't know about the issues
I don't care about the issues I I think
everybody should be able to live their
[__] lives as long as they're not
hurting each other
and then I understand why somebody who
wants to watch the wire do you know what
I mean and then they turn on some [__]
and you gotta see
you know
like this whole thing about trans uh uh
uh uh women or whatever in the
kindergarten talking about sexuality
with the kids it's like
not so dude it's nutso
it's not
but we talk about what we talk about and
honestly
I'm trans so [__] it
um
but I I brought this up because I put
this uh
uh like I don't know I just feel like if
I'm like I'm so not that though like I'm
so not about anytime that's my problem
anytime there's a somebody wants me to
be a part of a group I'm like nah nah
nah no no no no like when I was in
college and they were like you know we
got frats I was like bro dude you guys
there is no [__] way I'm joining
period you know when people are you know
that whole thing Join or Die all right
dude
make the gun talk to me because I'm done
dude I'm not
Join or Die you're gonna be like that
okay
I don't want to [__] join dude that's
why I hate all this pressure to become
you know
vocal about [__] issues when I don't
even know about the [__] issues and I
walk around and I see it in the world
and nobody knows about the issues
they're just like I'm just trying to
work
hey can I have a job
uh uh so yeah
the reason why I bring it up is because
I this is how I feel if you listen to
this podcast you know it's how I feel
right
um
and I posted a clip of me saying I think
everyone should be gay
um
here it's
right here
I posted this clip on from the last
episode or maybe it's the last episode
whoops no
it's this
old dude [__] [__] dudes straight up
I wish I could do it but it's like
you know bungee jumping for me I just
kind of I don't want to and so that
whatever I I I I and then so I put and I
I
um
Pride on it just as a joke and and it
they make it rainbowy which I didn't
know that if they did that maybe I
wouldn't
bro the [__] people
look I'm out of here sellout that he
says
chill bro
I'm actually gonna unfollow LOL
Chris is falling off now with this BS
look at Illuminati got him
the other guy [__] done with this
dude
guy right so woke dude it's the opposite
look sold his soul soul he said
bro really not you as well they acting
like
I'm on these front lines
everyone's a [__] I don't give a [__]
but also
I'm the you got the wrong guy unfollow
why won't this [__] charge my phone
won't charge great good good
is it not plugged in it's plugged in
fantastic fan [__] tastic dude
um fantastic it fell fantastic I don't
care
um
anyway dude I I don't understand the the
the people on the in they just the
Internet isn't real dude do you know
that
do you know the Internet isn't [__]
real it's absolutely Bonkers it's crazy
dude
like I kind of want to be on everybody's
side but the interview that's why I say
don't push me the internet makes you
have to pick a side and if you don't
then they'll do it for you
I I I am the product of the environment
that I was raised in that's what Tupac
said and when I was 16 I go like this
he's right and now he's right more right
than ever
um
uh yeah
it's so weird all of this is so weird
and I don't I think honestly in 10 years
we're gonna look back on this time and
we're gonna be like yo that was crazy
huh all of it all of it I don't mean the
issues I just mean all of it everything
that's happening I mean Donald Trump
posts like silly memes of his of his
Rivals the the president do you know
what I mean
Joe Biden
can't stand up uh period what I don't
understand is Joe Biden he just keeps
falling down hey guy just sit down
right you could be the president and
just keep sitting FDR nailed it the guy
couldn't walk and everyone's like yeah
hey Biden stop trying
just sit down if that dude just sit down
and stop talking
dude we would be [__] killing it
that's Biden whoops
ladies and gentlemen Joe Biden whoops
oh [__] he fell hey bun you okay
oh [__] hey
sit in a chair put some [__] wheels
on it
and then Trump's all out there just
[__] putting me dude it's bonkers
it's bonkers
and look I have literally the [__]
left will be like [__] this guy for
saying this and then the right will be
like [__] this guy's a sellout because
of the left because because all of it is
crazy
all of it is crazy dude all of it all of
it
anybody who's too right or two left is
[__] bat [__]
period
batshit
if you're not in the middle you are
um
and that's what's up and dude walk
around
see it
get off the internet go see it because
this is the stuff that [__] is
incendiary
you talk about black lives matter is it
good in essence yes it's a nice idea did
the founders of black lives matter buy
[__] mansions and stocks with the
money that was [__] given to Black
lives matter I mean that's what they say
if that happened ah yep you piece of
[__]
but you all know this
you all know this
if you take funds allocated for
something that's supposed to do
something and you don't do that thing
and you do the other things like by
mansions and put it in stocks you piece
of [__]
it doesn't mean that the idea of black
lives matter is a bad idea at its core
but you start doing all that other [__]
see that's what happened and guess who
else does that by the way the government
they all do this [__]
they all do this [__] they take the
funds and they go like this These funds
are cool and I will allocate them for
the things but also check out that
Maserati that's what they do because
that's human nature
and you know
so it's like you know it is what it is
tough out there you know
stuff out there and I'm not even
political baby
I'm not political at all
you know
the most political I ever get is when I
do the dirty Republican with my wife in
bed
sorry the lazy Republican
when I do the lazy Republican with my
wife in bed that's as political as I get
it's when you lay down next to the
person and the wife is in front of you
and you're on the side and you do it
like you would be doing doggy style but
you're both just chilling you know what
I mean that's a laser Republican
although now that I think about it
Republicans probably have sex like just
absolutely
invigorating sex you know
right
I feel like probably Democrats
have either like
well the safest weirdest
safest
non
dirty sex
because they're like
sign here or you know it's on the wall
if we're gonna do it you're like okay so
I don't know all right
put your thumb print here yeah cool
there we go I'll lay down and you enter
splurt splurt and we're splurting and
there we go okay cool now sign the wall
out time
um the Republicans are probably just
like
honestly dude this is when this is when
this is when Democrats do it
[Music]
and then this is when Republicans do it
dude
nope this one
just only a Blazer on
both of them
that's all out Blazers [__] just
getting all messed up with the tits all
out lopping around on the Blazer dude
whatever man we talk about what we talk
about my babies
and yeah dude I am going to be in
Nashville coming up September 9th so get
your tickets at chrysalia.com
um
everyone in my household was sick for
like two weeks but not me though Dude I
kept it real
not me
part of the reason I don't get sick is
because I don't allow it do you
understand that
I don't allow it
I feel it and I go
oh yeah okay I see what's going on here
I see what's going on here
yep
and I go like this hey
I'll get some rest we'll see where we at
tomorrow bro
a lot of times I wake up the next day
and I'm better
sometimes I wake up the next day and I'm
not better sometimes I'm worse
but you can't convince my mind that dude
I truck through it I trucked through it
and I started snapping at people because
I don't want to admit that I'm sick and
then people say [__] like
hey um
you know I'm in the bathroom and someone
knocks or something I'm like why do you
think I'd be in here you think I'd be in
here for any um longer length of time
than I would necessarily be or what we
think I'm doing it in here [__] a DJ
set
I'm I'm either pooping or I'm pooping
right because it's taking too so long so
I obviously I have a problem so you
don't need to knock on the toilet right
ain't that the truth huh cause whoever
the [__] hangs out in a coffee being a
tea leaf bathroom for any other reason
than they need to because they're
[__] [__] huh
all right
we can find it on the thing computer so
here I just play it on my phone
this guy
a few examples of how you can worship
your partner's [__] you can take one of
these things and do it or you can
combine a few or even all of the
examples that I'm going to give you in
one [__] worship ritual I mean [__]
is [__] gazing simply look at your
partner's [__] and
hey we call that pervan
you want to worship the [__]
look at the partner's [__] just look at
it [__] gazing stare at it it doesn't
matter if you're in public they have a
skirt and get lower [__] look at it
okay
um also
getting inside her a way to worship it
thrusting in and out splurting right
thinking of other women when you're
inside a [__] think of another [__]
and healing things that you can do
especially because so many women
experience a lot of insecurities about
how the revolver vagina and [__] looks
like imagine the guy dude how insecure
you'd be after that guy saying that to
you
that's why I like to go wow that is just
absolutely beautiful you know what you
might be insecure about that but boy I
gotta tell you that's beautiful that's
what I do
that's what I do as soon as I see it for
the first time too I did it to my wife
that's how I got her
I say
yo whoa whoa hold on a second
what is going on there that is beautiful
sweetie
sweetie doll that is a beautiful
beautiful beautiful part on you
what's the uh where's the uh
that's amazing guy
damn I don't have it do I have it
it should be there right
you did it didn't you
being expressing you or the reason tell
her how beautiful her [__] is tell her
how delicious she tastes yeah okay
imagine going down there and just being
like hold on hold on a second hold on
stop the cap that is gorgeous that
tastes gorgeous hold on a second stop
the cap that tastes good sweetie sweetie
doll stop the cap
you're insecure about this
sweetie doll
this is unbelievable this is just great
tell her how wonderful she smells oh you
smell great sweetie this is amazing
that's me another wonderful ways of
course
touch your palate and feel and feel
depth of love and gratitude God this
feels great this just feels absolutely
fantastic me during during intercourse
this now I don't know why you're
insecure about this but God does this
feel good that's me during intercourse
life-giving pleasure giving Source let's
make a baby
tips of your fingers as you are touching
her as you are giving her pleasure catch
her playfully in a way that explores
another another tip to do [__] worship
like you mean it ow Dude Perfect
eat her like you mean it dude that is
100 if that's not an R B song
hey baby I'm a girl imma eat you like I
mean it
girl a lot of guys just be laughing imma
be eating it like I mean it
you turn like it's the most delicious
meal you've ever I mean don't chew it
you know tasted your entire life
don't eat her because you have to don't
eat her because you try to make her eat
her
Dahmer
I'm gonna eat her because you think she
would like it eat her because it's the
most erotically alive the most desirable
and the most pleasurable thing that you
can do and lastly and especially if you
are spiritually oriented
in your life is to really perform an
elaborate ritual involving worshiping
your power
[Applause]
with smoke and [__] and look hey I uh
hey uh lay down baby hey uh baby lay
down hey uh hey uh hey uh take your your
clothes up at least your bottoms baby
hey uh uh hey I'll put your shirt over
your tits you know how I like it hey I
uh Hey a bunch of them up there we go
hey uh hey uh and here we go here we go
oh God God that was great sweetie don't
I don't know why you're insecure about
that it feels absolutely amazing the
house is on fire god damn it baby get
out get out put your clothes on and get
out no skip the clothes get out run to
the neighbors
[__] it can be something along the line
of your partner sitting at the middle of
a circle of flowers you know example you
can light candles and nonsense and you
sit and meditate in front of her vagina
you can offer some flowers fruits or
sweets and the greatest part about this
you can do this on the subway
offerings for the goddess as well as
incorporate everything that feels
creative
and joyful and playful and fun for you
to incorporate in that ritual after you
perform that kind of ritual you can also
take that and incorporate everything
else that I've spoken about and perform
any of these things as a part of the
ritual as well examples well that's
creepy tell me more about that
you can take
combine it you know
I mean the guy just so has slept with
eight women in his entire life you know
has slept with eight women and uh
foreign each of them each of them under
10 times
well that's creepy tell them more about
that dude everyone
oh God
sweetie doll
do you think undressed yeah undressing
the pants like this
sweetie doll
this is yeah
I know a lot of women are insecure about
the downstairs area but hold on a second
this this one right here that you have
it's just unbelievably beautiful
all right come on sweetie doll let me
talk you know what I'm gonna perform
that there we don't mess up the circle
of flowers but sit right here
okay now let me start this here fire
there we go let me get my big banana
leaf here we go let me just touch it see
that's wet see now the deal with that is
it feels amazing right I don't know why
I know sometimes the thing to do if
you're a woman and you've got you know a
lot of women are Instagram but the way
this one feels is just absolutely bunker
City
oh my God
sweetie doll I'm gonna eat it let me eat
it and let me just see what this is oh
my God
well hello
that is the greatest thing I could do
for me
uh hey uh hey uh now I'm just gonna add
more all right the house is on fire get
out
[Laughter]
oh [__] man
they're just so good man
and yes I'm gonna be in Montreal coming
up so go to chrysalia.com to get tickets
uh
see ya dude but that's that's worshiping
it I don't think honestly you should
worship uh anything iron Chic is dead
dude that I feel like that's crazy man I
used to talk to him and stuff on Twitter
when I used to do Twitter
that he was very cool man I'm sad he
died
um so rest in peace to the to the Iron
Sheik dude
um
you know I think that's
he should uh he should um
he should uh definitely uh have Beyond
people's minds because it's because it's
beautiful
um I'm gonna take a break here for a sec
dude did you guys see this thing first
of all I didn't know about
this at all
until today
when was this do you know
yesterday all right okay so I'm not too
bad here
um Conor McGregor
punched out
a mascot in Mascot gear
this whole idea is so stupid apparently
he was supposed to knock out quote
unquote a mascot
uh
and he actually did
um here look mascot stunt gone wrong
within Denver hey good morning Michael
it was a strange scene Conor McGregor
was not all right but it went to the
hospital here we go
this morning the man inside this mascot
costume is recovering after this
knockout punch from mixed martial arts
Superstar Conor McGregor sent him to the
hospital in a halftime skit gone buddy
hit him twice
at Center Court at halftime of game four
of the NBA Finals between the Denver
Nuggets and Miami Heat dude McGregor
came out for a special promotional
appearance for his new pain relief spray
with Miami fans booing McGregor the
entire time the skit called for McGregor
to pitch the product to the crowd until
the Heat's mascot Bernie appeared in
boxing I mean worst idea
followed by this a second one I mean hit
him so hard the second round
but Conor McGregor just lost his mind
you know he's [__] he's just zero to
a hundred just there's no 50 miles an
hour you know
dude so
[__] dumb that idea I mean dude the
idiots that come up with this [__] uh
pain medication by the way took him to
hospital
the result something the organizers of
the prank hadn't planned on yeah yeah
we're playing Bernie taken to a local
emergency room given pain medicine and
released they should just give him the
spray dude the [__] thing comes out
for pain relief spray and then the boxer
mascot comes out and he's supposed to
spray him with it and then ends up
knocking him out that's not even a good
skit oh what what do you mean like they
should be all over the what could go
wrong thing
you know what deserve at scale that we
talk about this is a 10 right here
the [__] stupid goofy bird came out I
don't even know like Miami Heat mascot
like it's just so dumb dude bizarre skit
going viral all weekend he coach Eric
spaulstra summing it up with some dark
humor so Miami Heat toughness that we're
talking about
that's not dark humor
you know
with some dark humor I have AIDS
I have AIDS I eat children wow okay that
was dark toughness that we're talking
about
spolster also said that should there be
a game six in Miami on Thursday Bernie
would be cleared for action and good I
mean dude just get a different guy you
know he's got a big ass bird head on him
it's all good man it's all good
god dude bits and skits and [__] so
here's what I'm thinking you know
anytime you got to deal with that guy it
sucks so here's what I'm thinking here
we do
call me
dude
call me asparagus
asparagus there isn't a bigger [__]
idiot on the planet than DJ Khaled you
know and he's laughing all his way to
the bank he just started golfing and
he's just like uh
I'm coughing every day and then he was
on the cover of Golf Digest dude all
these [__] companies are such [__]
you know God [__] Golf Tiger Woods play
me I golf now I go off so much and he
hits the ball in these [__] screams
everyone on the [__] Golf Course is
so pissed off that
we the best you hear Way Way Beyond in a
different we're the best
I play golf I I go off every day now
just so bored I'm done making music I'm
a golf I golf I'm a golf X I'm a golf
bag I'm a bag now put your clubs in me
I'll I'll stand on my head upside down
put clubs in my anus I'm a golf bag we
the best
imagine you're playing [__] Golf and
you're like a 65 year old retired white
guy and then all of a sudden in the
background you just hear
I'm a golf Aficionado I'm a golf bag
get the night on out of my anus it's
time to use it
I'm asparagus
I'm ex I'm gonna have an espresso and
eat an asparagus dude just wearing green
clothes you know
so unfucking creative
call me asparagus just
limping so hard
that is so
corny
call me asparagus
dude it's so corny that he's friends
with Mark Wahlberg too you know the two
of them hang out they [__] hate each
other
and they hang out so much call me
asparagus like you think [__] Mark
Wahlberg wants to hang out with a
[__] yuck Knuck like that two New
York New York's hanging out yeah
just two [__] curlies just chilling
hey what's up DJ Khaled call me
asparagus oh okay um
dude I nothing I hate more than two
celebrities that become friends because
they're celebrities I can't [__]
stand that it's so annoying then they
act like they were always friends and
they're dude they [__] hate each
other trust me I know I've been in these
rooms I'm arguably a celebrity they
[__] all hate each other and they act
like they're like best friends and like
somebody makes it and when somebody
makes it then they're in pictures with
other people that are [__] already
made it it's so shitty dude it's why
everyone [__] hates Hollywood because
they sniff this [__] out you think
Mark Wahlberg is friends with DJ Khaled
this [__] sucks
I buy Mark Wahlberg as friends with
Mario Lopez I buy that they're basically
you know
they work out together probably they're
both very religious but then DJ Khaled
comes along and is just like
call me asparagus dude it's so dummy
says asparagus wow that's so annoying
call me experagus
okay you know okay grandpa just lost his
[__] mind all right oh here comes
Grandpa he's probably gonna say see
something call me asparagus okay uh
asparagus
asparagus all right oh God damn it
wore that outfit once too you know
unreal
I don't know what's wrong with these
[__] people but who cares
I love this [__]
[Music]
Southern Nevada is a buzz tonight with
stories about the crash of an unknown
object and the alleged sighting of
strange creatures in the backyard of a
Northwest Valley Home such a mouthful
you know what dude dude the [__] got
through that and was sweating so hard
and got through it and unbelievable dude
I love when all newscasters and
reporters have to do is say allegedly
and they can't get sued for millions of
dollars you know that's the best is that
there's just one word that absolves it
yeah he murdered nine people allegedly
if you say if you drop allegedly that
you go to jail dude for defamation
that's crazy brother it's just a word
it's basically abracadabra
and then everyone just believes it too
Southern Nevada is a buzz tonight with
stories about the crash of an unknown
object and the alleged sighting of
strange creatures in the backyard of a
Northwest Valley Home such a [__]
mouthful dude it was last night that
eight news now investigator David charns
reported about how Metro Police
responded back on May 1st after
receiving a strange call from a very
dude it's not aliens you know they're
[__] idiots that they interviewed
as you know this is not our first UFO
Rodeo we first heard about he's so
pissed that they have to do it too it
doesn't believe in aliens okay here we
go hard they later heard footsteps on
their roof they saw one of the eight
foot tall creatures climb behind them
dude
this is [__] news
come on
later heard footsteps on their roof they
saw one of the eight foot tall creatures
climbed behind the controls of a large
front loader stored in the yard as if
trying to engage it oh yeah also they
did mushrooms first got a good look at
the creatures he said a greenish grayish
being with large eyes and Long Legs he
says he could hear its deep breaths and
when he locked eyes he was in essence
Frozen in place couldn't move in the
dude I don't believe anybody who's
Frozen who says and I couldn't move
because you can do it you can't believe
somebody who thinks that they lock up
because they're scared when you can just
[__] keep walking dude these [__] and
oh and the aliens let me guess dude yeah
they all had big eyes and they were
lanky and eight feet tall oh really dude
they all look like the cover of that
book communion that my dad used to read
back in the [__] 90s all of them dude
they all look like that just once just
once I want them I want to hear it was
actually crazy how much they all looked
like BB King and they had a guitar too
the middle of the yard where the object
had crashed then vanished oh god dude
you know killer impression was left in
the soil okay where is this on your
property these are my favorite police
dispatcher initially wondered whether to
send a crisis intervention team that's
the meaning they think he's crazy the
troubled witness but then took the
incident seriously two officers arrived
38 minutes after the call too long if
they're aliens dude everyone have been
Zapped to high heaven
officers showed up after a donut and
some coffee and took a [__] [__] and
then they went by then it heard from
other officers they proceeded cautiously
and managed some nervous laughs I ain't
dealing with that
so nervous man I ain't dealing with that
dude we gotta add that's the most
nervous lessons I heard the [__]
Jay-Z laugh
ERS they proceeded cautiously and
managed some nervous laughs I ain't
dealing with that
that's a match dude a few days later the
family says two Metro sergeants returned
to the scene to ask followers is so
boring you know I saw men in suits and
sunglasses driving in a car with
government plates dude they're just
[__] some men in black and went to
sleep you know this [__] stupid
[__]
wow I cannot how is this on the [__]
news this is so stupid this is on the
news hey you know what I'm not ready to
talk about aliens until you got the
footage
or you got scientific proof and I do
think there's aliens out there but I
don't want to hear all this [__] oh
yeah a guy in [__] Montecito saw a
[__] thing and it was eight feet tall
and they called some [__] and then there
was a [__] outline in the ground you
know
I heard its breath dude and slowly past
the house in the following days Nellis
and Creech have denied any interest or
involvement with the incident Metro has
indicated they believed the family that
something crashed in their yard but what
you mentioned George in that piece that
you know they were frozen because so
many people have been critical of like
why didn't get their phone out why
didn't they video do we know if there's
even anything uh yes and no so there's a
surveillance camera in the backyard yeah
property owner keeps that because he's
like got a lot of expenses and let me
guess what we were told is that at the
moment this thing comes down and crash
this camera went out oh right dude what
the [__] is wrong dude how is this on
CBS News Now
oh my god dude so here so here's the
deal
it didn't happen
everyone who [__] sees alien dude
let me get this start you take your cell
phone out the video every single aspect
of your life with somehow three of you
didn't take your cell phones out
videotape alien crash in your backyard
are they trying to put this out because
this is this is 5.7 million views are
they just doing this because they think
you know we know it's not true and it'll
just get clicks
I mean men in suits and glasses dry and
sunglasses driving a car with no with
with government plates you know
it's just [__] men the guy saw Menace
the guy literally ate weed brownies
watch Men In Black and fell asleep and
then woke up and called that's what
happened there figured it out next thank
you figured it down next
good
unbelievable
let's look here
uh deserve at scale
what could go wrong
what could go wrong carrying a t
carrying a TV on a motorbike well
oh God
machine
oh my God it hit the top of the [__]
thing couldn't even see
oh there's someone in front of it okay
why didn't they why first of all why is
there that thing even
why is there a thing that you have to go
under when it's just in the middle of
nowhere that's there so nobody steals a
[__] TV and holds it tall
that's so [__] hilarious that that
thing is even there there's just a chin
up bar in the middle of a parking lot
you gotta drive through
pretty good actually how well they did
considering that deserved scale is
probably nine because they should have
they should have
they didn't get too hurt it looks like
and then also they're wearing helmets so
that's good but also you're a [__]
idiot for doing that
um
what
oh don't work the next one looks like it
don't work yeah
it did that one after that works
oh none of them work oh the Reddit ones
don't work okay weird
okay here we got one
oh it's just Instagram that doesn't oh
here we go here we go here we go here we
go what's this guy doing trying to jump
to yep yeah dude [__] yeah that is a 10.
that is a 10. let's watch it
ten you [__] idiot whoa dude guy
tried to jump the [__] line what do
you call those the the poles that
separate the lines at the this is a
Coffee and Tea Leaf or some [__] no is
it Kohl's whatever it is I don't know
what it is the dude first of all
let's look at this here we go again all
right so first of all only wearing socks
slippery floor so that's the hot the
count is high you get three points for
that trying to jump over this thing at
all you get at least two points for that
being [__]
doing it the idea of actually executing
it three more points this once you get
the number one
didn't even jump at all dude jump this
High dude jump this high was was [__]
literally the jump was shorter at when
he was jumping than when he was just
standing
um
the best part oh crash hit his face [__]
yeah dude you deserve it all time ten
ten and was wearing a mask doing it
ten a hundred percent ten
oh [__] yeah dude friend just videotaped
it sucks guy deserved it 100 percent
that was a 10.
here we go Instagram fail army yeah
woman
oh God she's gonna hit the police oh no
no
yeah woman oh God she gonna hit the
police
the guy
oh no she gonna hit the police and then
does man
dude did wait
wait did we ever did we ever look at
this video on this podcast
top five videos I've ever seen and I
just I don't think we've ever looked at
it oh no
I shouldn't have I shouldn't
her
up driving hold on
where is it please find it
please find it
this is so funny
oh no
oh it's called oh no
I shouldn't have
oh please dude
do you know this one
oh dude it's so funny please find it
um
here here
crash
cry out to me yeah
oh God damn it well I mean what are
these videos coming up
it's just crazy
um
I mean they're stupid
filters
uh video
all right hold on guy tries to I gotta
do this is the funniest [__] video
guy tries to wake
up driver and
that's it dude what is it called
shouldn't
have
got it hell yeah dude bro have you seen
this
have you seen this oh dude this is
let's watch this
bro
I think this top five videos of all time
he gets out of the car goes to a guy
sleeping on his car knocks on the window
this is great
wakes up Carson
all right
it's the stop sign so slowly that it's
just going the guy's still recording it
goes off
oh [__]
[Laughter]
the guy says oh [__] I shouldn't have
woke him up dude like
like dude try like dude all he wanted to
do was yeah
[Laughter]
that's why you don't help nobody dude oh
my god dude he woke oh my God the
[__] way this is played out dude I
swear to God this should win this is
best picture whatever year this was was
picture oh my god dude it's the funniest
thing I've ever seen dude he gets out of
the car and then films the whole thing
quietly and then when the guy hits the
light the Lamppost and goes slightly
over the embankment he says
it is
[__]
bro
this guy's so drunk you know
I mean could have killed someone just
goes across traffic with our watches
again holy [__] this is funny
the bus just just narrowly missing the
bus hits the stop sign
how's this guy recording not saying a
word right now
and then still not saying [__]
oh [__] you'd have [__] up oh [__]
that one's so bad I think that's top
five so it's the [__]
it's so these are the top five so now
it's locked in place that one
the oh [__] I shouldn't have woke him up
chocolate croissants
um the tech TV one the yeah I don't know
if that that might be top five that oh
it just got me a piece of that just got
me that might be top five yeah and then
the tech TV one would you know that one
right okay dude those are the top five I
think see now it's locked in place
oh [__] I shouldn't have woke him up
that's so good dude that's it for the
episode on YouTube if you want to catch
the raw the uncut the extra episode uh
on patreon then go for it patreon.com
crystalia
um and uh it is a uh it is six dollars
and you get all the backlogged episodes
that's only on patreon only episodes and
all that um but yeah thanks a lot leave
a comment thanks
[Music]
thank you